Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
Nassim Barak :
Mes cousins ont tué ses cousins.
Jawad Essaid :
Mes oncles ont abattu les siens.
Sophie Mourani :
Nous sommes issus d’un peuple meurtri
par quinze ans de guerre civile.
Nos communautés religieuses
se sont massacrées, bombardées,
kidnappées, égorgées.
JE : Cette guerre nous
a divisés et déchirés.
NB : Là, on a bien plombé l’ambiance.
SM : La grande majorité du temps,
il se passe à peine cinq minutes
avant que l’on nous demande :
NB : « Eh, t’es typée ! Tu viens d’où ? »
SM : On nous pense d’origine italienne,
israélienne, espagnole, corse
ou encore d’Afrique du Nord.
JE : Beaucoup moins souvent pour
des Normands, on est d’accord.
(Rires)
SM : C’est vrai qu’on n’est pas
tout à fait blancs, ni tout à fait noirs,
NB et SM : Comme lui.
SM : On est très souvent trilingues.
Un outil de plus pour
brouiller les pistes,
parfois avec un fort accent.
SM et JE : Comme lui.
NB : On nous dit commerçants
depuis des siècles.
On nous dit fêtards - et ça c’est vrai.
(Rires)
Dans les pires moments de la guerre,
on continuait à faire la fête
et regarder tomber les obus au loin.
JE : On vient du pays
de tous les contrastes.
Très rares sont ceux qui l'ont visité et
beaucoup nous disent instantanément
qu'ils auraient aimé y aller.
SM : Et vous connaissez tous
la fâcheuse expression
« C’est Beyrouth. »
Vous l’aurez compris,
nous sommes des Libanais.
(Applaudissements)
JE : Nous sommes très connus pour
l’hospitalité et la cuisine libanaise,
la meilleure cuisine au monde.
NB et SM : C’est sûr.
JE : Dans les restaurants traditionnels,
vous commandez d’abord
les entrées ou « mezzés »
qui vont de 16 à 64 par table,
même si c’est pour deux.
(Rires)
Et quand il y a de grandes tablées,
ça devient complètement dingue.
On ne peut plus poser ses coudes.
SM : Alors, on ne va pas vous
donner la recette du taboulé.
C’est un secret d’État
mais on va juste préciser que
le taboulé libanais n’existe pas
puisque le taboulé...
Ensemble : Est libanais.
(Rires et applaudissements)
NB : Le Liban est un tout petit pays
de 10 000 kilomètres carrés.
L'équivalent d'un petit
département français.
Et pourtant tout le monde en entend
déjà parler ou a connu un Libanais.
Il se situe à proximité
de la Syrie, Israël, Palestine.
Un voisinage très calme, très recherché,
les pieds dans l’eau.
(Rires)
La population libanaise compte environ
5 millions d’habitants sur son territoire
et une diaspora de 16 millions
répartis dans 70 pays différents.
Ensemble : Nous sommes partout.
JE : Mais ce n’est pas très étonnant
car le Liban est un pays qui attire
autant qu’il repousse.
La guerre sans fin a chassé
de très nombreuses personnes
et la diaspora n’a cessé de grandir
au rythme des multiples exodes.
SM : Pourtant, le Liban
a connu de belles années.
A l’indépendance obtenue en 1943,
tout allait bien,
les gens étaient heureux.
Le Liban était un modèle
pour la liberté individuelle,
un modèle de liberté
d’expression et de religion.
Le rayonnement intellectuel
du Liban était mondial.
NB : La liberté était telle
que tous les dissidents des pays voisins
venaient se réfugier chez nous.
Dans les années 70, le Liban
était le quatrième pays au monde
en croissance économique,
avec un système bancaire en plein essor,
ce qui nous a valu le surnom
de la Suisse du Moyen-Orient.
SM : C’était le paradis,
une vraie réussite du vivre ensemble.
JE : Il faut savoir aussi que ce tout
petit pays est une mosaïque religieuse
où cohabitent dix-huit
confessions différentes.
NB : Oui, le Liban est
une démocratie pluriconfessionnelle
basée sur le poids démographique
de chaque confession.
Par exemple, le président de la République
doit être chrétien maronite,
le Premier ministre doit
être musulman sunnite,
le président du Parlement
doit être musulman chiite.
SM : Cette répartition se retrouve
sur toutes les strates de l’État
où la religion prime sur le mérite.
NB : Par exemple, Jawad,
tu ne pourras jamais être président.
Étonnant, quand même.
JE : Chaque citoyen est
dans une case bien précise.
Chaque nom, chaque village
ou quartier au Liban
est associé à une communauté religieuse
et donc souvent à un parti politique.
Notre confession a une telle
importance qu’elle est même inscrite
sur nos cartes d’identité
et nos fiches d’état civil.
SM : Cette constitution était
censée représenter et protéger
tous les individus,
quelle que soit leur religion.
C’était une sorte de
démocratie consensuelle.
JE : L’idée aurait pu paraître bonne.
Ensemble : Mais...
NB : Avec le temps,
le poids démographique a changé
mais le pouvoir, lui, n’a pas changé.
Les inégalités entre les différentes
communautés se sont accentuées,
créant des tensions telles, qu’en 1975,
la guerre civile a éclaté
et ensanglanté le pays
pendant quinze ans.
Ce fut la première
guerre civile médiatisée
sur toutes les chaînes
de télévision du monde.
Les reportages se sont invités dans
votre JT tous les soirs jusqu’en 1990.
JE : Vous avez été témoin d’horribles
massacres à Damour, Sabra et Chatila
et j’en passe.
Le début d’une fracture
intercommunautaire totale.
SM : Le Liban a inévitablement sombré
petit à petit économiquement.
La corruption s’est installée à tous les
étages de l’État et de l’administration.
A tel point que la classe politique,
toutes confessions confondues,
est comparée à une mafia
qui dirige le pays.
JE : Le peuple a été pris
dans l’œil du cyclone
et a subi, impuissant,
la descente aux enfers de son pays.
La haine a été attisée,
les préjugés se sont installés
et les communautés
se sont encore plus divisées,
laissant présager un futur bien sombre.
SM : L’histoire de ce tout petit
pays est tellement complexe
que même les Libanais n’arrivent plus
à suivre et à se mettre d’accord.
De ce fait,
il n’existe pas de livre officiel
pour apprendre l’histoire
du Liban aux enfants.
NB : Alors que c’est le pays qui a
sûrement le plus de lignes Wikipédia
au kilomètre carré.
(Rires)
JE : Résultat, en quelques décennies,
nous sommes passés de paradis
à parodie
en se tolérant les uns les autres.
Il n'y a plus de vivre ensemble.
Chaque communauté s’est retranchée
dans son quartier, son école,
ses bars, ses cafés.
Chacun pour soi.
Une autre sorte de guerre.
SM : Silencieuse.
NB : Alors bienvenue au Liban
où plus rien ne fonctionne.
Encore moins les services de l’État.
On va vous apprendre à ce propos
une expression typique :
« Hayda Libnen ».
« C’est le Liban et c’est normal. »
SM : Jawad, tu veux manger une glace ?
JE : Avec plaisir.
SM : Trop tard, elle a fondu.
Il n’y a que 6h d’électricité par jour.
Si tu veux regarder la télé,
tu peux prendre la batterie de ta voiture.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
NB : Vous voulez aller aux toilettes ?
Prévoyez le seau d’eau
et n’imaginez pas avoir de
l’eau chaude pour votre douche.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
JE : Tu veux prendre ta voiture ?
Tu ne peux pas.
C’est la pénurie d’essence après
avoir attendu des heures à la station.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
SM : Tu veux épouser
la femme que tu aimes ?
Impossible si elle n’est pas
de la même confession
car seul le mariage religieux existe.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
NB : Mais les amoureux
ont contourné le système.
Ils vont se marier à Chypre
et reviennent enregistrer
leur mariage au Liban.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
(Applaudissements)
JE : Dernièrement, la monnaie a perdu
90% de sa valeur en à peine un an.
Imaginez-vous gagnez 1 000$ par mois
et du jour au lendemain, cela
devient l’équivalent de 100$.
Alors que les prix ont augmenté.
Une boîte de lait pour bébé correspond
à un sixième du salaire minimum
et 20 litres d’essence
à la moitié de ce salaire.
SM : 80% des Libanais vivent
aujourd’hui sous le seuil de pauvreté.
L’argent public est volé.
Les banques ont fermé.
Les retraits sont restreints et
les sorties de capitaux interdites.
C'est banqueroute à Beyrouth.
Riches ou pauvres, Druzes,
Chiites, Sunnites ou Chrétiens...
Ensemble : Tous dans la même merde !
NB : C’est le quotidien de ce peuple
qui subit les conséquences dramatiques
de ce qui l’a divisé.
En ce moment, les Libanais
braquent leurs propres banques
pour retirer leurs propres économies,
pour payer l’hôpital à leurs proches.
On est bien loin de
la Suisse du Moyen-Orient.
D’ailleurs, au dernier classement de l’ONU
sur les pays les plus heureux du monde,
le Liban est avant-dernier
juste devant l’Afghanistan.
SM : Ouf !
NB : Rien n’est perdu,
on ne peut que remonter.
(Rires)
JE : Et puis, en 2019,
le gouvernement annonce la mise
en place d’une taxe sur WhatsApp.
Le seul moyen de communiquer
sans se ruiner.
C’est la goutte d’eau qui a
fait déborder la baignoire.
SM : Pour la première fois,
face à tant d’injustice,
de corruption et de ras-le-bol,
le peuple tout entier est
descendu dans les rues,
tous âges et toutes
confessions confondues.
Une révolution est née des entrailles
du chagrin et de la colère
et elle a duré un an.
NB : Les Libanais étaient enfin
réunis dans un même but :
sauver leur pays de l’effondrement,
changer le système politique confessionnel
et faire chuter le gouvernement corrompu.
SM : Tous étaient dans la rue pour
demander des droits fondamentaux
que vous considérez
constamment comme acquis.
De l’eau, de l’électricité, de la justice,
un système de santé et de scolarité.
JE : C’était une révolution de velours,
pacifique,
avec de la musique et des DJ partout.
Les gens dansaient, chantaient, criaient
dans toutes les rues des grandes
villes où ils s’étaient rassemblés.
À ce moment-là, tous nos clivages
n’avaient pas leur place dans l’arène.
C’était la première révolte
d’un peuple uni dans la tourmente.
SM : Une sorte de thérapie pour tout
un peuple qui n’a plus rien à perdre.
Tous citoyens de la même patrie,
rassemblés sous le même drapeau.
Du Nord, du Sud, jeunes, vieux,
les Libanais avaient enfin compris
que ce qui les avait divisés
les avait rendus plus faibles.
NB : C’était magnifique à voir.
Résultat, le gouvernement est tombé
et on n'en a pas eu pendant un an.
Pas grave, c’était le premier signe
d’unité nationale depuis 45 ans
et le début du chemin
de la réconciliation.
JE : Et nous, les Libanais à l’étranger,
on était plein d’espoir pour
transformer ce pays en profondeur.
On était impliqués, soudés et solidaires
avec tous les Libanais du monde.
NB : Parce que l’identité libanaise
se transmet de génération en génération,
même si on n’y est pas né.
Chaque génération transmet à la suivante
ses peines, ses joies, ses traumatismes,
sa force de se relever et d'avancer.
JE : On appelle ça
la résilience, n’est-ce pas ?
SM : Notre compatriote, Roda Fawaz,
dit qu’être libanais,
ce n’est pas une nationalité,
c’est un métier.
NB : Être libanais est un métier répétitif
qui consiste à basculer en permanence
de l’espoir au désespoir,
de la joie à la tristesse,
de la fête à la colère.
JE : Être libanais est
un métier de névrosé.
Pour certains, c’est aimer le Liban
mais être incapable d’y vivre
et pour les autres,
c’est maudire le Liban
mais être incapable de le quitter.
SM : Être libanais est un métier
pour lequel on signe un contrat à vie.
On peut quitter le Liban mais
le Liban ne vous quitte jamais.
Où que vous soyez, il vous rattrapera.
NB : Hélas, la Révolution s’est essoufflée
sans vraiment s’éteindre.
Mais il fallait bien nourrir sa famille
avant de changer le système.
JE : Notre capitale,
Beyrouth, a été détruite
par des guerres et des séismes
et ensevelie sept fois.
Et sept fois, elle a ressuscité
de plus en plus belle.
NB : Mais le 4 août 2020,
ce fut la huitième.
Stockées depuis six ans
en plein centre-ville
et sans aucune mesure de sécurité,
et à la connaissance
de nos politiques véreux,
2750 tonnes,
2750 tonnes de nitrate d’ammonium
ont éventré le cœur de Beyrouth
en une fraction de seconde.
Ce fut la déflagration non nucléaire
la plus puissante de tous les temps.
(Bruit de la déflagration)
SM : Cette double explosion meurtrière
a crié à notre pays et au monde entier
que la mort n’a pas
de religion ni d’origine.
215 morts, 6 500 blessés
et 300 000 réfugiés dans leur propre pays.
Ce fut le coup de grâce
pour le Liban déjà effondré.
JE : Dès le lendemain,
tous les Libanais étaient
de nouveau dans la rue,
main dans la main,
toutes confessions confondues,
tous âges confondus,
à nettoyer, déblayer, aider
et accueillir les sinistrés.
Si cette révolution a fait
renaître notre fraternité,
cette explosion
a contribué à la renforcer.
NB : Et la diaspora s’est
de nouveau mobilisée
pour envoyer de l’argent, des médicaments,
excédée par cette corruption qui
a conduit à une telle catastrophe.
L’histoire se répète inlassablement
sous une autre forme de drame.
SM : Deux ans après la date
anniversaire de l’explosion,
l’enquête piétine
et ce n’est pas une surprise.
Aucun responsable n’est désigné.
Ensemble : Hayda Libnen !
NB : Même si le futur
du Liban est incertain,
notre espoir réside dans
cette nouvelle génération libanaise
qui a déjà déconstruit ses préjugés.
JE : Oui, ce tout petit pays
est au centre de la machine
géopolitique mondiale et régionale
et la situation intérieure n’arrange rien.
Avec les années,
elle est devenue si fragile
que nous voyons de l’espoir
dans la moindre poignée de mains
ou la moindre accolade.
NB : Mais pourquoi faut-il
que notre union ne se produise
que lorsqu’une catastrophe
secoue le pays ?
Pourquoi est-il si compliqué de régler nos
différends une bonne fois pour toutes ?
SM : Même s’il cumule les malheurs,
le Liban n’est pas un cas isolé.
Nombreux sont les pays qui se déchirent :
Soudan, Rwanda, Somalie, Syrie.
JE : Même s’il est microscopique,
le Liban est une parfaite
caricature du monde.
NB : On adore notre pays.
Mais s’il vous plaît,
ne commettez pas nos erreurs.
Intolérance ethnique et religieuse.
JE : Lutte de pouvoir.
SM : Creusement des inégalités.
NB : Accaparement des richesses et
corruption existent dans tous les pays.
SM : C’est juste qu’au Liban,
les curseurs sont tous au maximum.
JE : Et chez vous,
où en sont-ils ?
(Applaudissements)